Hey maryners und wilkommen zu einem neuen Video von mir. Heute geht es um Make up, aber im Gegensatz zu dem älteren make up Tutorial wo ich euch die
Schlimmen make ups von meiner schulzeit/Universität gezeigt habe
möchte ich heute ein tutorial zeigen wonach so viele gefragt haben.
Undzwar mein alltägliches make up.
Den ihr on meine instagram Stories gesehen habt und ihr mir so viele nachrichten geschickt habt.
Indem ihr gesagt habt das es mir erstens super stand.
Und ihr mir so viele Komplimente geschickt habt Und also WOW. Tatsächlich schminkt ich mich öfters so und zweitens euch
Natürlich euch den tutorial zeigen damit ihr auch versuchen könnt euch auch so zu schminken könnt.
Wenn es um den Augen Geht benutze ich nur diese Palette von sephora die sehr sehr
Nude farben hat, womit man sehr gut so ein make up bearbeiten kann.
Ich würde anfangen diesen Beige hier Aufzutrage
um so einen leichten Schatten zu bilden.
Secondo step facilissimo il marrone, il marrone lo andiamo a applicare
sulla punta esterna dell'occhio
e quindi andiamo ad accentuare
la sfumatura
l'ombreggiatura che avevamo creato con l'ombretto precedente
E andiamo a sfumare i due colori insieme
Dopodiché passiamo ad un colore molto più chiaro
e lo andiamo ad applicare sulla nostra palpebra mobile
In particolare nella zona insomma centrale o comunque dell'interno dell'occhio e andiamo a picchiettare
E vedete che si è creato questo effetto insomma di sfumato per
Enfatizzare ancora di più insomma, lo sguardo userei semplicemente una matita marrone
e andrei ad applicarla
Sopra insomma la palpebra mobile
Mi raccomando non vi preoccupate anche se avete fatto una linea troppo spessa, cerchiamo di non farla spesa però se vi
scappa la mano non è un problema perché poi andremo a sfumarlo con un pennellino
Quarto step il mascara
In questo make up diciamo che il mascara un ruolo fondamentale perché apre bene lo sguardo
Che è già stato enfatizzato insomma dall'ombretto e dalla matita, con il nostro mascara diamo il tocco finale
e quindi dobbiamo lavorarci un pochino, concentratevi vedete questi movimenti dall'alto verso il basso per
Aprire meglio le nostre ciglia, allungare
Andiamo anche a mettere un filo di mascara sulle nostre ciglia inferiori
Per quanto riguarda le labbra potete optare o per un effetto assolutamente
Naturale come nel mio caso ho soltanto il burrocacao
Oppure se vi piace
Comunque rimanere nelle tonalità nude ma senza qualcosa di troppo
Appariscente, io solitamente uso questo rossetto qua di MAC honey love
che dà appunto quell'effetto
Che è perfetto con questo make up e questa è un alternativa insomma
alle labbra
Senza rossetto senza tinta labbra. Il nostro make up è finito, mi sciolgo i  capelli così sembro un po' più decente
spero tantissimo che questo video tutorial vi sia piaciuto
fatemi sapere se vi piacciono insomma queste tipologie di video e soprattutto mi raccomando se
Riproducete questo make up taggatemi nelle vostre foto perché vi voglio vedere
Come al solito iscrivetevi al canale se non l'avete ancora fatto e attivate la campanella che trovate vicino al tasto d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti
I miei nuovi video. Inoltre vi ricordo di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social facebook instagram musically..
Vi mando un bacione e ci vediamo al prossimo video